all right well it's a great pleasure to
introduce um Bob dutta uh from very
close by our neighbor and actually my
neighbor and my friend so Bob got his uh
PhD and his MD from Harvard Medical
School in Michael Greenberg's lab uh he
went on to a postdoc with Richard Axel
um he's subsequently joined back came
back to Harvard and um is an associate
professor at Harvard Medical School and
Bob has done amazing work
um in in many many different domains so
ranging from understanding all Factory
codes to
characterizing quantitative Behavior to
basically looking across from you know
the sensory to the behavioral Arc
overall and everything in between and
he's going to tell us I think about some
of the stuff in between in dopamine
systems now so um welcome Bob and before
Bob I let you go on with your talk I
think Lisa is here so I just want to
acknowledge uh her being present so
foreign
hear me we're good excellent um so thank
you Ela for that kind of introduction
and for the invitation to come and speak
and congratulations both to you and to
everyone here on the founding of this
icon Center I think it's the right
moment to think about a sort of
Integrative computational Neuroscience I
will say that I was really excited by
your first slide where you kind of
described trying to integrate data
across many levels going all the way
down to genes and molecules I think it's
an idea that many of us have talked
about for a very very long time and
haven't really reduced to practice and
it feels like we're having a moment in
Neuroscience where that's really
possible so I'm excited for for this uh
this new icon Center and I look forward
to seeing the great work that comes out
of it
um okay so let's get going
have to stay on this side I think I do
oh there we go excellent Okay so
the behavior of animals in the natural
world where they're free to do what they
want when they want is obviously
remarkably complex
and it's because of this complexity that
to us as humans it often appears that
their behavior is fundamentally
inscrutable but of course the
ethologists working 50 60 years ago
hypothesize the spontaneous naturalistic
Behavior like this actually has a ton of
underlying structure they believed that
spontaneous behavior is actually
composed out of a series of Behavioral
modules brief three-dimensional
stereotyped repeated you know units or
motifs of action or movement that are
concatenated one after the other in time
to build complex behavioral sequences
and which are organized hierarchically
in time thereby affording Behavior a
kind of spatiotemporal organization
that's selected for by Evolution and
allows animals both to kind of deal with
the challenges of their particular
ecological niche but also enables them
just enough flexibility to adapt to
changes in context and contingency
they also made an argument that I think
all of us will find very intuitive which
is that if indeed there is a kind of
underlying structure to behavior it must
somehow arise in the nervous system
but despite the fact that this sentence
was written now nearly 60 years ago we
still I would argue have only the most
superficial understanding of how the
brain composes spontaneous behavior and
here by spontaneous Behavior I mean the
kind of behavior that you and I and
almost every creature spends most of our
day doing the kind of behavior that
happens in the absence of a task without
obvious and explicit rewards sometimes
without obvious goals the kind of
behavior that happens when you're not
confined behaviorally or psychologically
or physically
this question you know how the brain
composes uh naturalistic Behavior has
really haunted my lab for the last
decade and so to begin to address this
question we've been building tools that
allow us to characterize the underlying
modular basis for mouse behavior in the
laboratory with the and the idea is that
if we can begin to do that we can begin
to test this kind of ethological
hypothesis that behavior is built out of
parts
the tool we've built and we've been
working on is called motion sequencing
or moseq for short we've published a
bunch on this technique and so I'm not
going to describe it to you in any great
detail at all because I want to show you
just the data
um but at a very high level most seek is
an unsupervised machine learning
algorithm that based on the spatio
temporal structure of Behavioral data
alone without any human supervision or
intervention is capable of discovering
an optimal set of Behavioral modules or
what we call behavioral syllables out of
which behavior is composed in any given
experiment the behavioral data we tend
to feed motion sequencing is 3D imaging
of mice as they explore simple Arenas
like the circular open field over here
and we obtain these images these 3D
images by placing depth cameras which we
buy from Best Buy for like 100 bucks
over buckets that we get for five bucks
from Home Depot and you can see the
output of one of these depth cameras
here here heat map to over each pixel of
the mouse is its height at any given
position and you can get us you can very
much get the sense that these cameras
even though they're imperfected in many
ways give you a rich representation of
the animal's ongoing three-dimensional
post Dynamics and again we feed these 3D
data to the most seek algorithm which is
a generative time series model for
behavior that instantiates this
ecological hypothesis that behavior is
composed out of modules that tumble one
after the other somewhat predictably in
time and by fitting this mod this model
through unsupervised techniques uh you
know mostly discovers this kind of parts
list for behavior in a typical open
field experiment it discovers maybe 40
or 50 of these behavioral syllables
which correspond to human identifiable
behaviors things like pauses Dives and
and runs the average duration of each
one of these little behavioral syllables
is three four five hundred milliseconds
and so mostly
um teaches us about a kind of sub second
architecture that seems to be
characteristic of mouse behavior and we
can synthesize for any given experiment
the entire output of motion sequencing
into one of these behavioral state maps
here each node is a behavioral syllable
the diameter of each one of these
syllables represents how often within an
experiment that particular syllable is
used and the thickness of these
directional yellow arrows indicates the
observed likelihood of transition over
time from one behavioral syllable to the
next during the experiment and so I hope
you can tell just by inspection that the
behavior of mice in the laboratory is
captured by most seek just like the
behavior of mice out in the real world
is characterized by having an enormous
amount of structure and the question we
want to answer is
where does the structure come from how
does the brain build this and that has
got us thinking about parts of the brain
that are involved in building behavior
in specific cortical basal ganglia loops
and in particular the input nucleus to
the basal ganglia that's part of the
brain here in blue called the striatum
because of its well-known roles both in
action selection and in motor control
which of course are going to be
functions that are critical to composing
spontaneous naturalistic Behavior we've
focused on a specific sub-region of the
stratum a part of the stratum called the
dorsolateral striatum that's for a
couple reasons first dorsolateral
stratum or DLS gets input from
proprioceptive and motor cortices
suggesting the dorsolateral striatum has
access to the kind of information you'd
want if you wanted to organize your 3D
post Dynamics but also because work by
others in particular Kent barrage has
suggested that during simple spontaneous
behaviors like grooming the dorsolateral
spray and might play an important role
kind of in organizing those behaviors
and so for all those reasons we wanted
to test the hypothesis it may be the DLS
contains within a neural correlates for
Behavioral syllables behavioral grammar
right the sequences the sequence in
which syllables are expressed or both so
to address this question we have
rendered together with our collaborators
motion sequencing compatible with all
forms of neural recording and so now we
can use kind of Mosaic as a general
purpose platform for querying brain
Behavior relationships during
spontaneous behaviors so let me show you
an example of us doing this that's shown
here so I'm here on the upper left is
going to be a mouse running around in
one of these buckets
this is obviously a 3D image here we're
going to extract the movie the 3D movie
of the mouse we're going to align it so
its nose is to the right and it's tell
us this is to the left and we're going
to center it in this image
you can tell that this mouse is wearing
a hat out of which is coming a cable
that's because we've been planted a mini
scope within its dorsolateral striatum
and you can see what the miniscope is
visualizing here here you're looking at
calcium transients and individual spiny
projection neurons and dorsolateral
striatum and here in the center we can
line these two data streams up here on
the bottom looking at calcium transients
an individual spiny projection neurons
in DLS and up above is our post-hoc
identification of each behavioral
syllable as is expressed
sorry
so I'm a little bit under the weather
since when I perfect
okay so what you can see
even just by inspection there seems to
be some interesting relationships
between population level activity and
these neurons and the behavior that
animals Express is they freely behave
it's as if as animals switch from one
behavioral syllable to the next there's
a switching in the ensembles of neurons
that are activated such that a new
Ensemble of neurons is kind of dialed in
as the animal switches from one
behavioral syllable to the next and if
we formally analyze the data that's
exactly what seems to be true and indeed
if we look at the ensembles themselves
it turns out we can use the identity of
each syllable specific neural Ensemble
to make accurate predictions about the
specific 3D Behavior the animals
expressing at any given moment in time
in other words we can kind of look down
at the animal's brain and I can tell you
which syllable it's expressing on a
moment by moment basis in addition this
neural data contains related information
about the specific sequence contact
context in which each syllable is
expressed and if we lesion the
dorsolateral striatum animals continue
to appropriately Express behavioral
syllables from a kinematic perspective
but there they're ordering is totally
incorrect preventing them from
generating kind of adaptive sensory
driven behaviors and so what this tells
us is that indeed the dorsolateral
stratum seems like it's an important
place for organizing spontaneous
behavioral sequences but it fails to
tell us some of the answers to some of
the key kind of remaining questions
about where this structure comes from
for example why are some behavioral
syllables used more than others why do
some behavioral syllables like this one
tend to participate in highly
deterministic very predictable
behavioral sequences going from here to
here to here whereas other behavioral
syllables tend to be connected to a
bunch of other behavioral syllables more
probabilistically or randomly seemingly
participating in behavioral sequences
kind of more willy-nilly you know where
does all that structure come from so
thinking about that problem got us
thinking about the major neuromodulate
later that influences describe and that
is of course dopamine which is well
known to influence both population level
activity in medium spiny neurons in this
item and to be capable of inducing
plasticity in those very same neurons
which is why dopamine has been
implicated in a a large number of
different contexts as a teaching signal
the dopamine that talks to dorsolateral
stratum largely arises from neurons that
live in the midbrain and substantial
Parts compacta as shown here and there's
reasonable reason to believe that
dopamine might play an important role in
organizing spontaneous behavior and we
know that from thinking just about what
the behaviors that are changed in
patients with Parkinson's disease right
those patients have difficulties in
initiating new movements and
invigorating their movements and
appropriately sequencing their movements
that being said we actually know very
little about the role of dopamine during
spontaneous behavior in animal models
there's basically two lines of thought
about what dopamine might be doing in
animal models the first comes from work
of folks like Marie Costa and Dan
donbeck who've observed that his animals
are stopped and then generate a new
movement there tends to be a little
Flicker and dopamine suggesting that
maybe these dopamine flickers that are
associated with movement initiation are
causal and indeed if you kind of
optogenetically induce a flood of
dopamine and striatum animals will begin
a new movement there's another kind of
non-mutually exclusive set of ideas
coming from Henry yin's lab that maybe
dopamine Dynamics are actually quite
continuous and the continuous variation
in dopamine actually specifies the
animal's ongoing movement kinematics
but again as I've mentioned there
actually hasn't been that many careful
kind of recordings of dopamine as
animals are just spontaneously behaving
in any context so the degree to which
either of these is kind of a general
rule remains a little bit of a mystery
what is true and what we know a lot
about from 40 years of work is something
that I've already mentioned which is
that dopamine plays this key role as a
teaching signal and is capable of
shaping animals future behaviors in
order to assist animals in in kind of
maximizing their ability to obtain
rewards but it's hard to think about the
kind of rolled open might play as a
teaching signal helping animals to
obtain reward in a context like the open
field that I showed you or an animal is
running around in the dark with no task
no goals and certainly no reward right
and so most of our attention has been
focused on trying to understand whether
or not dopamine during spontaneous
Behavior relates to initiation or
kinematics okay so we began thinking
about this and we decided to do a very
simple experiment which is just to
repeat the experiment I showed you
before for but now to record dopamine
transients specifically in dorsolateral
stride and through the use of the
dopamine reporter delight and so here
we're doing the fiber photometry you can
see the mass running around in the
Bucket over here and here you're looking
at um
dopamine transients as reported by
Delight locked to syllables which are
being identified post-hoc and what you
can see just by inspection right is that
there are far too many dopamine
transients to be explained by movement
initiation alone
in addition if we do a ton of math which
we did we can we have a very difficult
time identifying any kinematic
parameters that seem to be encoded by
these dopamine fluctuations with one
exception and that exception is velocity
so what's interesting is that if we've
been the dopamine transients at
relatively short time scales at time
scales of five to ten seconds we
actually see a negative correlation
between the amplitude or number of
dopamine transients the animal is
experiencing and its speed in other
words if there's a burst of dopamine
during spontaneous Behavior animals
actually tend to slow down and that kind
of weird counter-intuitive result is
something that had been observed by
others in the field before what's
interesting is that if we've been the
data over longer and longer time scales
this relationship actually seems to
invert and now we have the kind of
comfortable positive correlation between
dopamine and movement that all of us
were taught kind of in our Neuroscience
classes where dopamine is thought to
kind of broadly invigorate or enable in
some way the animals the animal's
ability to generate movement
okay what about movement initiation per
se so this is what we see if we look at
movement initiations the x-axis here is
time times zero is the moment at which
the animal generates a new movement
after being still and indeed we can see
a nice little dopamine flicker as has
been observed in the past associated
with the initiation of a brand new
movement but the amplitude of this
flicker is much smaller than the
amplitudes we observe if we actually
um tee off this data on all behavioral
transitions so here Time Zero is
actually the transition from any
syllable into any other syllable right
so the animals moving here and it's
moving here there's just that the
movements are different and what you can
see are these nice large amplitude
changes in dopamine that systematically
reflect When Animals switch from
expressing one behavioral syllable to
the next it's as if the dopamine kind of
exhausts itself as the animal ends one
syllable and then then there's this
large upsurge in dopamine as animals
enter into and begin to express the very
next syllable so this is what we see on
average we see this large systematic
fluctuation and dopamine across all
syllable transitions this isn't actually
what we see if we look at individual
syllables if we look at individual
syllables we see a lot of variation in
the dopamine amplitudes that are on
average associated with any given
syllable so here we're identifying 40
different behavioral syllables in this
experiment and if we just look at this
very top behavioral syllable which turns
out to be a rear When Animals begin to
express this rear dopamine kind of
quickly ramps up
to this very high amplitude and then
characteristically Falls in contrast if
you look at this syllable down here at
the bottom this turns out to be a pause
When Animals Express a pause their
dopamine tends to be pretty low then
slowly during the expression of the
pause it ramps up if we look at any one
of these syllables we'll see associated
with it a characteristic dopamine
waveform now this might give you the
idea that we should be able to use these
waveforms or their amplitudes to predict
which behavioral syllable the animals
expressing at any moment in time in much
the same way as I told you that if we
look at actual neural activity and spine
projection neurons I can make accurate
predictions about which 3D Behavior
animals are expressing so if you try to
play that same trick with these dopamine
transients it turns out we can't make
predictions I can't tell you which
behavior the animal is expressing on a
on a moment-by-moment basis based upon
the dopamine waveform that's associated
with that behavior and the reason why it
becomes obvious if we just look at
different instances of this particular
behavioral syllable what we find is that
there's a huge amount of variability in
terms of the amplitude and waveform in
dopamine associated with any given
Behavior yes indeed on some instances of
this rear you see this kind of high
amplitude dopamine transient but on many
instances you actually see dopamine
going in the opposite direction that
holds true for all of the behavioral
syllables and so we can't make
predictions on a instance by instant
basis of which syllables being expressed
based upon the dopamine waveform and
this is broadly consistent with my
previous claim that it does not appear
that dopamine is encoding the kinematics
of the animal's movement here are four
separate examples of the animal
generating the same rear up behavior and
yet in in all four of these cases
there's a different dopamine waveform
that's associated with it right so so
this dopamine waveforms can't be
encoding kinematics so now we're in this
kind of weird situation right it's clear
there's a strong temporal correlation
between
dopamine kind of flickering as animals
switch from one syllable to the next
during spontaneous Behavior but it's
unclear what these flickers mean to the
animal they certainly don't encode
kinematics and they don't encode the
ongoing behavioral syllable so in order
to kind of clarify our own thinking we
did a simple calibration experiment so
all we did was we took some chocolate
chips and we just threw them into the
bucket and then we measured dopamine
transients as animals consumed these
delicious and surprising and rewarding
treats and what we observed is that the
doping fluctuations that were elicited
when the animals
um consumed these surprising rewards
which clearly in a different context are
capable of shaping the animal's behavior
were of roughly the same amplitude as
the fluctuations that we were observing
in dorsolateral straight striatum you
know during spontaneous Behavior and
that suggested to us a really surprising
possibility maybe these dopamine
fluctuations aren't actually controlling
the animal's movements in the moment
maybe they're instead controlling the
animal's movements in the future right
by reinforcing in some way the syllables
with which they are associated On Any
Given syllable instance if that is true
he would make a very simple and basic
prediction which is that those syllables
that are associated with the most
dopamine on average during the
experiment are precisely those syllables
that should be used the most on average
during the experiment and in fact as you
can see here on the left that's true the
x-axis here is dopamine the y-axis
here's how often a syllable is used each
dot here is a syllable Mouse pair and
indeed we see this nice positive
correlation revealing that those
syllables that are used the most are
those that on average are associated
with the most dopamine and what's super
interesting is that this relationship
between dopamine and syllable usage
holds true on a moment-to-moment basis
so if the animal is just kind of
generating behavior and are a particular
instance of a syllable say that rear I
showed you there's a high amplitude
dopamine transient then that particular
rear is going to be used more for about
the next three minutes as shown here by
this orange line and if that very same
rear on some different instance is
associated with a relatively low
dopamine transient then over the next
three minutes that specific syllable
will be used
now dopamine of course is not just
important to reinforcement it's
important to action selection in a whole
variety of different contexts that has
been shown and so we wondered whether or
not these dopamine transients that were
associated with individual syllables
played any role in determining the types
of sequences that syllables were
embedded in and so we just asked you
know when uh on average were those
syllables that were associated with
high levels of dopamine do they tend to
be embedded in more predictable
sequences or more random sequences and
it turns out as you can see here that
there's a nice positive correlation
between how much dopamine on average is
associated with a syllable and the
variability of the behavioral choices
that animal make that animals would make
in the future such that syllables
associated with hydropylene tend to be
embedded in more variable behavioral
sequences and syllables that are
associated with low dopamine tend to be
expressed as part of more predictable
less variable less entropic sequences
and again this effect seems to hold true
on a moment by moment basis if you're
expressing that that rearing syllable I
was mentioning to you before and you
happen to be associated with a high
amplitude dopamine Peak the next two
three or four behavioral choices you
make tend to be more variable ones you
tend to make a kind of more unusual Next
Behavioral Choice as shown here by this
orange line and conversely if you're
still if that same rear is associated
with relatively low levels of dopamine
the next thing you do tends to be more
predictable able and kind of more ho-hum
so now I've described to you three
things that appear to be correlated with
dopamine those three things are the
animal's velocity
the usage of individual syllables on
time scales of minutes and behavioral
variability in terms of sequence
variability evolving on time scales of
seconds and we've built encoding and
decoding models that kind of validate
all the correlations that I've that I've
just described I'm not going to show you
any of those models instead I want to
turn to our attempt to do a causal
experiment what we wanted to do was to
somehow manipulate dopamine specifically
during the expression of a given
syllable to ask whether that
manipulation would it would affect
velocity usage or variability so in
order to do this we've taken advantage
of the magic of deep learning which
allows us now to render motion
sequencing closed Loops so now we can
look down at animals freely behaving and
you know just running around in a bucket
and I can tell you with about a 50
millisecond latency or so which specific
behavioral syllable the animal is
expressing at any moment in time and
based upon which syllable it's
expressing I can pick out a syllable I
want to manipulate and I can send out an
optogenetic trigger and here we're going
to use those optogenetic triggers to
specifically cause dopamine release in
dopaminergic axons that live within the
dorsolateral striatum itself so it's a
very spatially localized manipulation of
dopamine and here we're going to do a
kind of unusual thing we're going to
calibrate our optogenetic manipulation
such as the amplitude of dopamine
release that we observe out here roughly
matches the amplitude of dopamine
transients that we observe when animals
are just spontaneously behaving and
practically what this means is that
we're giving a single 200 millisecond
long continuous wave pulse of light at
extraordinarily low powers
um and what that in turn means is that
this document this kind of optogenetic
dopaminergic manipulation we're making
which is spatially localized is far more
subtle
um in general than the sorts of
dopaminergic manipulations people have
made to implicate dopamine and behavior
and so it stood to reason and we
anticipated that this kind of
manipulation should not change the
animal's behavior at all and indeed if
we measure kinematic parameters either
within a given syllable or throughout
the experiment we see that these kinds
of calibrated manipulations in which
we're manipulating dopamine at the same
scale as dopamine is naturally
fluctuating have essentially no
consequence on the animal's ongoing
movements these dopamine transients that
we're inducing don't initiate new
movements they don't change the
kinematics of syllables they don't
change the animal speed or footage to
turn in other words these results
suggest that these natural fluctuations
and dopamine that accompany spontaneous
Behavior are almost certainly not causal
at least in dorsalateral striatum for
influencing the animal's ongoing
kinematics and and we know this isn't
just an artifact of our optogenetics not
working because if we just turn the
light on now for two seconds instead of
200 milliseconds now we see the usual
and expected dramatic changes in the
animal's movement in this other context
okay so it looks like these spontaneous
fluctuations aren't changing the
animal's ongoing kinematics what about
how often syllables are used so here we
see something very dramatic so here
we're just going to pick one syllable
out of the maybe eight or nine that
we've specifically targeted for
optogenetic pairing and reinforcement
here looking at some pre-stimulation
data just to look at Baseline expression
of this particular syllable which is the
rearing syllable I'm showing it to you
here in green
and what we see is that nearly
immediately as soon as we turn on the
light and begin to to pair the
expression of that rearing syllable with
dopamine within two or three pulses the
animal recognizes that there's some sort
of relationship between this very subtle
optogenetic manipulation we're making
and the generation of that particular
egocentric behavior and it begins nearly
immediately to upregulate the expression
of that targeted Behavior it does it
during the first session we give it a
little bit of a break it does it again
during a second section and we know that
this isn't just dopamine causing the
upregulation of the targeted Behavior
but instead it reflects learning and we
know that because the latency for the
animal to express the targeted syllable
on the second session is shorter than on
the first session and importantly if we
turn the light off we see this kind of
persistent expression of the targeted
behavioral syllable even in the absence
of this optigenetic manipulation
consistent with the animal Having
learned an association between dopamine
and this particular Behavior again
consistent with reinforcement and it's
one of mention what's kind of what I
think is kind of amazing here which is
that of course you know while we're
doing this the animal is just running
around in a dark empty bucket with no
sensory cues from the outside world at
all so the only way the animal has to
know that it's generating the targeted
behavioral syllable is through ephrine's
copies and proprioception but that is
sufficient for the animal to understand
its own behavior and to cause this kind
of targeted upregulation
okay what about behavioral variability
we can look at trials in which we add a
little dopamine and compare the animal's
subsequent behavioral decisions to what
we observed on those trials we didn't
add a little dopamine what we see is
consistent with what I showed you in the
endogenous data which is that on those
trials in which we add a little bit of
extra dopamine to a given behavioral
syllable the very next Behavior the
animal generates tends to be a less
likely or more variable behavioral
Choice whereas on those catch trials
where we don't do that the animal tends
to do more predictable things
and so it's clear from what I've told
you that that um these kind of
spontaneous dopamine fluctuations don't
seem to be influencing kinematics but
instead seem to be shaping the ongoing
structure of behavior both by
influencing behavioral choices in the
near future and I think most importantly
by reinforcing over time scales of
minutes the usage of associated
behavioral syllables and this suggests
that maybe these kind of these
spontaneous dopamine fluctuations that
we're observing are acting as a kind of
continuous teaching signal to sculpt the
architecture of behavior if and so we
wanted to kind of query that formally
and so to do that we've built a simple a
very simple reinforcing learning model
reinforcement learning model in which we
use actual data actual dopamine syllable
associations to train a reinforcement
learning agent and then we ask whether
or not the behavioral choices that are
made by this train reinforcement
learning agent match up with kind of
held out observed behavioral choices
that are made by real life mice and if
in fact they match up it would suggest
that in fact dopamine is acting as a
kind of teaching signal so here I'm just
to quickly explain how the model works
the state that the model is in
represents the syllable the animals
expressing at any moment in time the
action is the animal's choice of its
next syllable here we of course
substitute the traditional reward signal
for the dopamine that's associated with
any given syllable and we use Simple Q
learning rules to update a q table which
here is equivalent to a transition
Matrix that governs how any syllable
transitions into any other syllable
you'll notice here we're only going to
focus on transitions amongst the top 10
syllables that's because we're a little
data limited and you'll notice also that
there's some syllable transitions we
don't consider and that's because these
are syllable transitions that don't
exist in in the empirical data that said
you know we initialize this transition
Matrix uniformly and then we just kind
of train a reinforcement learning agent
using simple key learning rules and we
can learn a transition Matrix that
effectively reflects the behavioral
choices this reinforcement learning
agent would make if it were able to
behave in the real world and then we can
compare this High dimensional this
hundred dimensional transition Matrix to
an actual transition Matrix from held
out data and what's remarkable is that
we capture a huge amount of the
behavioral variation
that's observed in real life data when
we just train an RL agent using these
syllable Associated dopamine transients
and that really argues both the
continuous variation in dopamine might
be acting as a teaching signal and that
those signals might be interpreted by
animals as reward let's relax signals
just on this last data set I just want
to mention that everything that I've
shown you here is specific to
dorsolateral striatum if we go ahead and
repeat the exact experiments I've been
describing to endorsing medial striatum
we no longer see the correlations
between dopamine and behavior that I
described to before and we try to
optogenetically stimulate dorsal media
illustrate them now we can no longer
reinforce individual behavioral
syllables so to sum up I've described to
you at a kind of very high level motion
sequencing which allows us to atomize
behavior into components thereby
revealing this kind of underlying
structure to Behavior I've told you that
it seems like dorsolateral stratum plays
an important role in assembling the
behavioral sequences that are captured
by this behavioral state map and that
dopamine seems to play an essential role
in affording this behavioral state map
it's it's structure it does so not
through controlling the animal's
kinematics on a moment-to-moment basis
which is I think the kind of naive
zeroth order prediction you would have
made but instead and it's kind of very
surprising Way by acting as a teaching
signal to shape the future usage and
sequencing of behave several elements
during spontaneous behavior and what's
really gratifying about this is that of
course this this means that the role
that dopamine is playing during
spontaneous behavior is analogous to the
kind of role that dopamine has been well
characterized as playing during a much
more structured tasks when animals have
rewards it looks like the very same kind
of circuits and in fact the very same
computations that support kind of
reward-based goal-oriented learning seem
to come into play during spontaneous
behaviors suggesting a kind of unitary
function for dopamine in controlling the
overall architecture of behavior in
multiple circumstances and the key
remaining question is of course why does
dopamine vary right what's what's
controlling the variation in dopamine
thereby structuring Behavior that's a
problem for another day and so with that
I'll just mention that the work that
I've showed you today was largely done
by Jeff Markowitz who just started his
own Lab at Georgia Tech along with two
great graduate students when Gillis and
Maya J and all this work as part of a
broad collaboration I have with Bernardo
sabatini Scott Linderman and now with
Cheeto thanks for your attention
[Applause]
we have a few minutes for questions
um
yes
that's a good question so the reason why
we built these encoding and decoding
models was to get a sense there's going
to be some correlation amongst all of
them the correlations are pretty weak
but we wanted to get a sense of like if
we were to build a coding model for
example or a decoding model what's the
relative weight afforded to each one of
these kind of Behavioral features if you
wanted to for example predict the dope
like the the fluctuations in dopamine so
it turns out that each one of these
three things seems to play
a different and complementary role in
um in kind of recovering the dopamine
transients so all all three seem to
matter and what's interesting is that if
you look at the kind of the time scales
at which the beta parameters evolve it
turns out the velocity is important at
very very short time scales along with
sequence variability which is exactly
what I showed you in the correlations
and usage tends to be important over
much longer time scales which is exactly
what I what I showed you usage seems to
be reinforced for minutes whereas
variability and velocity seem to be
important over seconds and actually the
models capture those temporal Dynamics
and demonstrate that all it looks like
you know if you wanted to predict
dopamine you'd need all three of these
different behavioral features to make
accurate predictions
um yeah that was amazing how you pinned
down these relationships between
dopamine and the syllables I'm wondering
though since is this kind of dopamine
noise or reward noise that's happening
in these situations where the animal is
just walking around and you have these
kind of micro
unmotivated or or unexplained
fluctuations that have no purpose and
the animal's behavior is modulated by it
but not in any purposeful or good way
yeah so in my discussion which you know
there are many possibilities for where
these dopamine
um fluctuations arise and in fact
um
um David Kleinfeld has recently
published a paper in which essentially
stochastic dopamine fluctuations in the
cortex over much longer time scales that
I'm showing you here right these are
subsequent fluctuations his fluctuations
are over many minutes but you know High
amplitude dopamine fluctuation in cortex
are seemingly appropriated these random
fluctuations are seemingly appropriated
as kind of Windows of learning that
animals can take advantage of the shape
behavior in this kind of accidental way
we think that this is not accidental and
we have ideas about where these
fluctuations are coming from and the
reason we think it's not accidental is
because
um I think I kind of didn't have time to
elaborate on but which I think when you
think about it is pretty obvious is when
you throw a mouse in a bucket actually
it has characteristic and stereotype
type of Behavioral dynamics that evolve
in a really reliable way across animals
across time so you know when animals
first get into the bucket there's kind
of exploration mode then they kind of
are in this like less exploratory mode
and then they're in this kind of chill
out mode and that's all very stereotyped
so the fact that like Behavior itself
has very stereotyped temporal Dynamics
is difficult to reconcile between
um you know and and if dopamine is in
fact reinforcing it's difficult to
reconcile those two things and so we
think it's not noise I mean formally it
could be it's Choice number three in our
discussion of possibilities right but I
think it's likely to be something we
think it's likely to be
um the output of some sort of
computation that's actually shaping the
animal's behavior and if you'd like me
to speculate on what I think that
computation is I'd be glad to
I was intrigued by your observations of
dopamine dips around the transition
points of syllables and it it sort of
aligned with a question that I had
generally have which is that it seems
like you're treating dopamine as a sort
of prospective
signal and rather than looking at it as
sort of a retrospective signal and I'm
wondering if you've looked at the stop
like explicitly the stoppage of
syllables associated with the dip since
one syllable stops before another begins
and sort of related to that if you with
your optogenetic stimulation if you look
at what's happening before your
um your stimulation I realize you're
doing this in closed loop with a
specific syllable so it makes sense that
that one is reinforced
um but I I'm I I guess I'm wondering
about sort of your framework and
thinking about it sort of prospectively
rather than retrospection yeah so you
might imagine right that either just in
the endogenous data when we look at
correlations or in the in the
optogenetic data there might be some
temporal slop right that like maybe when
I reinforce a syllable it doesn't just
reinforce that syllable but you might
expect that it would reinforce like the
behavior that led to that syllable the
syllable before right retrospectively or
you might expect that it could you know
maybe you know be a teaching signal in
the kind of interior Direction so we've
done all of the sorts of things you'd
want us to do right we've we've taken
the dopamine signals and like lagged
them out forward and backwards to see
whether or not the correlation still
hold in all of our models we do that as
routinely as a control so it turns out
that um the reinforcement that's that
we're predicting based upon an
endogenous dopamine fluctuation really
seems like it's temporarily associated
with the syllable that's attached to
there is a little bit of slop maybe you
know like the amount of reinforcement
goes down by a factor of a log okay to
the two temporary adjacent syllables and
that's it we can do the same thing in
the reinforcement learning model right I
showed this beautiful transition Matrix
like if we just shift over the
relationship between behavior and
dopamine by one syllable that
relationship goes to almost nothing so
it really is quite precise actually
which is a little bit surprising and
interesting I'll say that we've built a
model in which like a prediction you
might make is that those syllables that
on average are associated with the most
dopamine should be those syllables that
show the greatest degree of
reinforcement if our exogenous
optogenetics is being is kind of being
added to the endogenous fluctuations
that prediction turns out to be true
again kind of centering our attention on
the syllable that we're actually
targeting but you're right you know
there is some slop in both directions
there's a little bit of retrospective
slop there's a little bit a little bit
of prospective slop I also mentioned
starting since I get to talk right I
also mentioned one one thing about this
which I think is really interesting so
you know the duration distribution of
the syllables has a mean that's like 4
500 milliseconds but the actual
implementation of syllables is often
much longer than that and what that
means is that we're shutting the light
off and the dopamine transient that we
induce is off
nearly always before the syllable is
completed
and yet syllables stay intact so if
Behavior were truly fully continuous and
not discretized in any way you might
imagine that like we would be
reinforcing just the front half of each
syllable or just a part of the syllable
that was associated with our optogenetic
manipulation actually that's not true
syllable durations don't change at all
when we do this optogenetic manipulation
only usages change and that suggests
this kind of intriguing idea that maybe
there's something discreet about
Behavior at this time scale which is
very consistent with the things that you
were talking about earlier today which I
I love that work about autocorrelations
across cortex and I and I very much have
been thinking about the idea that maybe
those kinds of time scales are setting
these discrete time scales that are used
by the brain to organize sensation in
action into little bundles that make
sense to the brain that's a that's a
speculative idea we can talk about at
dinner
great fantastic I'm sorry let's do it at
post
so please hold your questions and and
bring them to Mom
[Applause]